le mar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame vous manqués vraiment de charisme
vous manqués vraiment tempérament et
vous madame
quand on délivre ses messages on est
plus tranchant voici les messages que je
recevais de la part de mon directeur de
magasin
à l'époque je travaillais dans une
grande enseigne de distribution
d'articles de sport mon job faire le
maximum de chiffre d'affaires et que
tous mes collaborateurs soient engagées
et investit dans la même direction
j'avais l'impression que ça se passait
plutôt bien pour moi mais chiffre était
bon mais collaborateurs investi mais
pour mon directeur de magasin
j'avais un sérieux problème pour lui
je manquais de leadership leadership
vous savez vous ce que c'est le
leadership moi personnellement
à l'époque j'avais aucune connaissance
de cette notion tenez si je vous demande
de fermer les yeux et de réfléchir
quelques instants à des leaders
quelle personnalité
quel personnage vous viendront à
l'esprit allez-y fermer les yeux
réfléchissez peut-être ferez vous partie
des neuf personnes sur dix qui quand on
leur demande de réfléchir à un leader
penseront automatiquement un homme fort
puissant dominant et charismatique
vous penserez peut-être à barack obama
au général de gaulle ou à nelson mandela
alors forcément pour mon directeur de
magasin me voir moi en tant que leader
c'était un peu compliqué mais bon il
m'avait dit sarah inspire toi d autres
responsables alors c'est ce que j'ai
fait mais j'ai pris conscience que dans
mon magasin tous les autres responsables
étaient des hommes
les seules femmes en magasin elles
étaient soit en caisse soit en vente
autant vous dire
mais aucun rôle modèle aucune figure
inspirante
vous savez ce sont ces femmes sur
lesquelles on peut s'inspirer ce sont
ces femmes qui ont briser le plafond de
verre
cette barrière invisible qui les
empêchent de progresser aussi rapidement
dans les organisations que les hommes
voilà pourquoi vous ferez peut-être
partie d une personne sur dix qui quand
on évoque qui quand on leur demande de
penser à un leader pensera
automatiquement à une femme vous
penserez peut-être à simone veil mère
teresa ogre et attenberg pourtant elles
aussi ont réalisé des choses
extraordinaires
alors à force d'entendre tous ces
reproches de la part de mon directeur de
magasin au bout d'un moment je me suis
sentie nul il légitime et en manque de
crédibilité
alors j'ai donné ma démission mais j'ai
donné ma démission avec l'envié
chevillée au corps de comprendre cette
chose que je n'avais pas le leadership
alors figurez vous que le leadership
c'est très simple il n'y a pas besoin
d'être à la tête d'une grande entreprise
pour faire preuve de leadership ni même
être un président d'un grand homme un
grand pays non nous sommes tous capables
de faire preuve de leadership mais
leadership c'est d'avoir une vision une
idée une conviction profonde et de la
partager à ceux et celles qui nous
entoure c'est être au service du
collectif pour que ceux et celles qui
vous entourent atteindre atteignent
ensemble des objectifs partagés
vous voyez c'est très simple
tenez vous par exemple madame dans votre
entreprise
lorsque vous laissez votre porte ouverte
pour que tous vos collaborateurs
puissent venir s'exprimer aisément sur
leurs projets leurs idées leurs
aspirations
et lorsque vous les écoutez avec
bienveillance vous faites preuve de
leadership et vous monsieur dans votre
association
lorsque vous mobiliser des âmes et des
femmes autour d'une cause qui vous tient
à coeur vous
faites preuve aussi de leadership et
vous madame qui est enseignante
je vous garantis que lorsque vous
mobiliser 30 élèves autour d'un projet
scolaire qui vous tient à coeur
et lorsque vous transmettez vos savoirs
avec passion vous faites preuve aussi de
leadership vous voyez c'est relativement
simple et je suis sûre que nous avons
tous quelque chose à partager autour de
nous il suffit de connaître nos
convictions nos valeurs ce que nous
avons envie de défendre à ceux et celles
qui nous entoure mais pour en revenir à
mon histoire
malgré des chiffres qui étaient plutôt
bons et mes collaborateurs investi mon
directeur de magasin continue à me faire
des reproches
et alors là ça a été une grosse
préoccupation pour moi je me suis
questionnée je me suis demandée suis-je
en tant que femme
un leader différent des hommes
existe-t-il un leadership masculin d'un
leadership féminin
eh bien figurez vous qu'à travers mes
travaux de recherche
j'ai pu souligner qu'il n'y avait pas de
différence majeure entre les hommes et
les femmes en matière de leadership
non ce n'est pas parce que je suis une
femme leader que je serai naturellement
douce bienveillante et dans l'empathie
et inversement
ce n'est pas parce que je suis un homme
leader que je serai naturellement
autoritaire dominant et directif nom le
sexe de l'individu ne détermine pas ces
comportements de leadership
par contre oui par contre nous avons
tous des représentations en matière de
leadership et quand on pense à un leader
on pense automatiquement un amant et on
l'a vu tout à l'heure et il nous faudra
quelques secondes supplémentaires pour
penser à une femme
pourquoi
parce que ce sont des années et des
années d'ancrage des rôles confiés aux
hommes et aux femmes dans nos sociétés
est historiquement la sphère du pouvoir
la faire de la représentation la sphère
de l' influence était confiée aux hommes
alors que la sphère privée intime
domestiques étaient confiées aux femmes
voilà pourquoi il est si rare dans nos
entreprises de voir des femmes à des
positions de leadership et ceci entraîne
deux conséquences pour elle d'une part
elles sont considérées comme moins
crédible pour exercer des fonctions de
leadership et d'autre part une
évaluation de leurs compétences plus
défavorable comparativement aux hommes
qui n'a pas déjà entendu
oh là là j'ai une femme manager elle est
autoritaire directive les pires qu'un
homme alors que ce même comportement
déployés par un homme est considéré
comme normal et inversement
cette femme là pour se passe de
direction je la sens trop émotive trop
sensible alors que ce même comportement
déployés par un homme serait considéré
comme de la bienveillance et de
l'empathie
alors que faire comment changer les
choses écoutez bien une étude du forum
économique mondial de 2018 nous dit que
si nous restons sur la même longueur
d'onde nous parviendrons à la parité
dans 202 ans vous allez bien entendu 202
ans
c'est cette génération c'est ma fille
aujourd'hui qu'à cinq mois qui ne verra
jamais la parité dans le monde du
travail mais finalement l'enjeu n'est
pas tant de parvenir à la parité pour
juste se dire qu'on atteint un équilibre
que de changer notre représentation
changer nos représentations
oui je ne vous cache pas que ça sera
très difficile parce que ce sont nos
ancrage nos automatismes mais les études
nous disent que à partir du moment où
nous prenons conscience de nos
représentations nous sommes capables
de l'échangé alors finalement un leader
c'est quoi vous imaginez un dessin
d'enfant un gros bonhomme avec une
grosse tête des bras et des jambes et
bien derrière cette image d'enfant on
peut voir l'image d'un leader
cette grosse tête elle permet de
diffuser une idée une conviction des
valeurs si une tête pensante et ses bras
ils permettent d'unir de fédérer de
rassembler derrière cette idée et ses
jambes ses jambes
elles permettent d'avancer de
transformer de bousculer les choses et
finalement derrière ce beau nomme ça ne
serait pas aussi une bonne femme
vous voyez le sexe de l'individu
n'importe peu mais c'est aussi changer
nos comportements
vous trouvez ça normal dans nos
entreprises de couper la parole aux
femmes lors des réunions ou de
s'approprier leurs idées comme si
c'étaient les vôtres messieurs non
personne ne trouve ça normal
alors que c'est l'exercice même du
leadership partager ses idées
et puis il est temps d'arrêter toutes
ces petites blagues sexistes qui sous
couvert d'être fort sympathique et
rigolote peuvent laisser les femmes sur
le banc de touche
et puis nous oui nous mesdames nous tout
osons ozon prendre la parole aux ondes
défendre nos idées
osons défendre nos convictions je suis
sûr que nous serons aussi des pionnières
pour d'autres femmes
enfin il est temps de ne pas confondre
abus de pouvoir et leadership comme
l'avait fait mon directeur de magasin
qu'est ce que je peux lui dire merci
patron
car grâce à lui je peux partager ce soir
avec vous ce qu'est le leadership et
puis aujourd'hui c'est mon métier d'être
professeur de leadership
alors n'oubliez pas notre monde serait
tellement plus puissants si nous
faisions tous preuve de leadership et
n'ont pas de pouvoir alors demain oser
défendre vos idées
oser défendre vos convictions osé
prendre votre place et oser faire preuve
de leadership et en attend pas 202 ans
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]